hey guys my name is Jess Mattel it is
the 30th of June today and I have a
bunch of gaming news to fill you in on
so let's get right to it Insomniac Games
has dropped some brand new knowledge on
the upcoming spider-man game yes for the
developer applied to some fan questions
on Twitter where they explained they
have a huge team working on the game and
the spider-man is being developed using
insomniacs internally developed engine
which was last used to create ratchet
and clank for ps4 the dev have confirmed
that the upcoming superhero title will
be stand alone and not tied to next
year's spider-man homecoming film
insomniac is pretty damn busy of late as
they're also working on some of the deep
as well as VR titles edge of nowhere the
unfocused and feral right all right now
this one may be reaching a little but
when they're just got a hit that left 4
dead 3 is in development although
wishing for third entries from valve is
always a tall order I've discovered by
fansite valvetime a reference to the
third installment in the zombie riffic
franchise was spotted in valves
development community wiki in a tutorial
about final destination concept artist
Tristan rates had posted a picture of a
file directory and inside bar there's a
bunch folders one of which is named left
4 dead 3 the picture was quickly taken
down and replaced with one that did not
include the suspiciously titled folder
of course nothing has been confirmed by
valve and this is merely the latest in a
bunch of left 4 dead 3 references that
have been uncovered over the last few
years finally would you can be listen up
for just one more story as the Bioshock
remastered collection is indeed a thing
that's coming in a way as we strongly
suspected 2k have confirmed that a
remastered anthology of bioshock
bioshock 2 and fireship inputs are
coming to ps4 xbox one and pc fire
jacques the collection will run you 60
of your dollars and learn
the US in September 13 Australia in
September 15 and internationally on sep
tember 16 the collection includes all
three games and their DLC as well as the
director's commentary featuring director
ken Levine and lead artist Sean Rogerson
what once we included is bioshock tues
multiplayer and the pc version of
buyshop interest will not be remastered
as according to 2k it already meets
current gen console standards and run
smoothly on prior visual settings the
compilation is being developed by blind
squirrel games who collaborated with
irrational games on the development of
the original BioShock Infinite 2k have
confirmed that all of the games will run
at 1080p and up to 60 frames per second
across all platforms additionally 33
players are eligible to get the
collection for free if you already have
one of the Bioshock games on Steam you
can get a free upgrade to the remaster
let me know down in that comment box if
you're keen to pick up the collection
and be sure to head to games but we've
got stories on wreck-it Ralph two and a
little big planet be sure to pop by same
time tomorrow for the biggest stories of
the week I'll see you then